Hello there. My name is Raymond Whitcomb
and today I'm going to talk about
recursive coding agents, which is this
idea of applying
the lessons of recursive language
models, RLMs,
to coding agents. This is some work that
I have done both in my independent
research
um
Raw Works
uh and also more recently
in my role at OpenProse.
So,
to motivate this a little bit, we all
want outcomes. We all want agents that
are working on our behalf. We want
reliable co-workers that are getting
things done while we're doing something
fun, while we're out on a hike, while
we're cold chilling, while we're
doing the do.
And
my argument and my experience is that
the bottleneck to this is not
intelligence.
The models are
intelligent enough. They know all kinds
of things. They know the entire
internet.
But they can't reliably deliver
outcomes. And so I can't trust them.
So, as a very simple example, you know,
one day I get almost a fully working
SaaS app from a single prompt, granted a
long prompt.
The next day, and I swear this actually
happened,
cloud code empties the entire contents
of my Solana wallet. Oops. Okay. So,
that
doesn't really instill trust. So, uh at
the bottom here we got this this
progression, okay? And we all want to
move towards the the one on the right
where we're just sort of sitting there
and meditating and and things are
manifesting. And so, where does that
come from?
This is from the AI engineer code.
It's actually from the back of the
t-shirt. AI engineer code, November
2025. Man,
I hope I hope you're there.
If you weren't, watch it on YouTube. It
was
it was amazing.
So, here's the thesis. The thesis is
today's agents are mismanaged geniuses.
The intelligence is there, and the
missing layer is how do we specify and
manage and reuse and verify
the work.
So, this uh framing this phrase, the
mismanaged genius, uh comes from Alex
Zeng, Z Li, and Omar Khattab at MIT. Um
and Alex and Omar are uh part of the
authors of the original recursive
language models paper.
Uh I've also talked a little bit about
this recently on Turning Post.
I forgot to mention that these slides
are actually a website,
recursivecodingagents.com.
So, you can click on them
uh by going to this website. So,
everything I'm going to show in here is
is interactive. Okay. What are recursive
language models?
So, I like to say that in an RLM, the
context itself is the object of
computation.
Um and
this is essentially a marriage of tool
calling and reasoning. We're going to
talk a lot more more about that in the
next slide. But, the idea is that the
full prompt is not a simple user query.
The full prompt is a variable. The full
prompt could be a file or many files.
Um and we have this read-evaluate-print
loop, REPL,
um that the agent is interacting with.
In the original paper, that's Python.
And the RLM is instructed to operate
symbolically on that prompt. So, don't
just read the whole thing into your
context window.
Um explore it symbolically.
And uh even more,
you don't even directly explore
symbolically, or maybe you do a little
bit of poking around, but have
uh other LLMs, uh and I guess other
RLMs, if you allow the recursion depth
to be to be greater than one.
Uh
have these uh
other recursive um sub agents and and
again we'll get
uh a little bit into the the weeds of
the the lingo
um sub RLMs sub LLMs
uh do this symbolic manipulation
to pick apart the answer and then work
our way back up to a final answer. So,
it looks something like like this in
this in this tree below.
So,
my take here is that RLMs are the new
reasoning models and I see this as
the next paradigm of test time compute,
inference time compute, whatever you
want to call it.
And why does it seem obvious or maybe
like hey, why is this even a thing?
Um I think it's very elegant because
it's a very elegant marriage of two
things, reasoning and code execution.
So, the code execution
is reasoning.
Um and so instead of we we had long um
we had chain of thought as a prompting
strategy that evolved into reasoning
models that explicitly expressed the
chain of thought as the reasoning
tokens. We already had function calling,
tool calling, parallel tool calling, um
and RLMs really puts that together
in a way that gets amazing results. So,
three very simple examples, one from the
original paper U Long, the RLMs can
process
information that is many orders of
magnitude larger than their context
window, tens of millions of tokens. Uh
what I showed in my own independent work
was that the default RLM harness is
itself a really powerful memory system.
Um so, RLM with no modifications is
essentially like a top 10 memory system
and like you know, up there with all the
people custom making memory systems and
there's probably billions of dollars
going into that.
Um and uh with a little bit of
modification, you you can get really
amazing results uh using it as memory.
I was also able to show state-of-the-art
results where the RLM framework and
specifically the DSPy
implementation of it was able to get
state-of-the-art uh results on long
reasoning tasks. Now, there's this new
benchmark Long CoT. I won't go into the
details in depth, but the idea of this
benchmark was that the problems are hard
specifically because they require so
many um steps of reasoning
uh in in the like analysis sequence or
the chain of thought
um that most uh reasoning models,
including the top ones, can't hold the
thread for long enough.
Um if you allow
the
uh RLM to solve the problem uh using a
combination of code and recursive calls
to sub agents, then a very small model,
Qwen 3.59B,
you could run this on a laptop,
uh can actually beat So, Qwen 3.59B as
an RLM can beat
Opus and um
and GPT-5.4, all the top frontier models
as LLMs on these long reasoning tasks.
So, they're extremely extremely
powerful.
So powerful that they are
arguably too hot to benchmark. So, two
examples here, on the left, a very
high-profile
uh case where um
the Symbolica team has this RLM agent
harness called Agentica.
Within hours of Arc AGI-3 being
released, where the top scores of all
the frontier models were around two or
three percent,
the
uh Symbolica team showed 30-something
percent.
This is crazy. They blew it out of the
water within hours using RLMs as a
framework. So much so that is uh, very
much upset the Arc Prize team. And so,
uh, they gave them what I'm interpreting
as a consolation tweet. Uh, which as far
as I'm reading the situation was
essentially saying, you know, la-di-da,
congratulations, um, but you didn't
solve the problem the right way. And we
don't like RLM harnesses. And so, uh,
you can have this nice tweet, but we
refuse to actually do the full private
part of the ArcadeGI evaluation. Uh,
which to me is just insane.
Uh, in my own uh, work and and on the
long COT benchmark,
um, my results as well as Alex uh, from
MIT, the RLM first author,
uh,
encouraged, let's say, the uh, the uh,
leaderboard
maintainers to actually make like a
separate open harness leaderboard. Uh,
so that the the results of the RLMs
could be showcased without contaminating
the
original intent of the leaderboard,
which was basically no tool calling is
allowed. So, my take on this is I don't
care. I don't care whether it's latent
space or reasoning tokens or code
execution. I want results. And I want AI
programs that get those results.
Okay, so this can feel close to a lot of
other things. And I have I built a
little rubric. There's a companion
GitHub repo for this that you can go
through if you want to see.
Um, and so, what do we need to be an
RLM? We have an executable environment,
the prompt is externalized, there's code
that's actually the thing calling the
model, the model is able to pick the
decomposition of the problem into the
sub calls or sub agents,
and the state itself is staying
symbolic, right? So, obviously plain
LLMs and rag and things like that don't
don't meet those.
Coding agents and sub-agents and loops,
they get close, but they're not quite
there. And again, this rubric here is
not to like start fights or nitpick.
It's just trying to explain like what
what's the essence of of RLM
and recursive coding agents.
Another example that's close but no
cigar would be hardcoded map reduces.
And I would put
this this project of lambda RLM in that
category, which is essentially a way of
saying, "Okay, I'm going to decompose
the problem using lambda calculus into a
map reduce." And then there are like LLM
calls in that executing the map reduce.
But the But the LLM is not deciding or
the RLM is not deciding how to decompose
the problem. And that I see as like a
key element of this that makes it very
agent native, you might say.
Okay, so now RLMs, what about recursive
coding agents? Okay, it looks the same
to me. We just swap RLMs and LLMs for
agents and sub-agents.
And don't we have the same thing?
And yeah, you do. And I think that you
could take this perspective of haha,
trick question, like RLM is a coding
agent and it's already recursive, so
what did I
And that's fine, and I don't think that
argument is wrong, but it doesn't really
move anything forward. And so, what I'm
interested in is this question of how
can we apply the principles of RLMs to
coding agents and make them actually
useful for coding agents. And I've been
very obsessed with this problem since
the October RLM blog post came out in
2025.
Okay, so I'll show some of my
experiments on recursive coding agents.
The first one
was simply wrapping Alex's RLM package
as a CLI. So, the idea was I just want
to give my coding agent an RLM as a tool
call. So, let's say we go we need to go
sift through a 100 million token corpus.
Uh well, now I just use this that tool
and then the RLM does the RLM thing.
So, that's interesting.
And it can be very useful. Uh and a few
other people have built uh things like
that.
Uh but then I thought, "Well, what would
it really mean? What would be possible
or how could it be possible
to make the coding agent fully
recursive? So, the coding agent
harness like calls itself, like the
exact version of itself.
Um and how might you implement that? And
that is what I called Y pie. Uh Y stands
for
the lambda calculus uh Y combinator.
And pie, in case you haven't heard of
it, is really awesome coding agent. It's
incredibly minimal and it's specifically
designed to be extensible. So, Mario
uh wants you to write extensions for pie
for new features that you would like
rather than trying to stuff your ideas
into the the main um agent. So, it's
meant to be a very minimal core that you
extend however you like.
And when I originally had the uh
recursive coding agent idea, I wanted to
do it with pie.
I was not able to
use pie extensions to achieve this goal.
Um
and so, I had to fork it instead. I'm
very excited to report that in
anticipation of this talk, I revisited
this and now pie has evolved um and the
pie extensions have evolved such that
you can
uh make it fully recursive with a pure
extension. So, I have both the pure
recursive
um extension pi recursive uh package as
well as the y pi wrapper that is like a
convenience wrapper for this. So, this
is very
quite literally a recursive coding agent
in the sense that pi calls pi calls pi
calls pi. You can set the depth however
you want. Um
and now I want to show a few other
notable projects in the space. So,
obviously there's the original uh
implementation from Alex RLM. DSPY
pi.rlm is uh my go-to uh when I'm
especially doing benchmarking.
Um that's how I got all these amazing
results uh on some of these benchmarks.
AXE, I think is a very interesting one
because it's incredibly agent native.
So,
the AXE started out as a TypeScript
variation on DSPY. When RLM's came out,
they obviously implemented it uh but
they did it in this way that's um
enables then AXE agent to like write a
whole TypeScript interface to another
AXE agent and go all the way down uh the
the recursive rabbit hole um which I
think is really cool and very
interesting.
Just to showcase that this like REPL
could be anything, there's a an example
from Dan at OpenProse who made the Unix
RLM.
This is pure bash and the environment is
just the Linux file system. So, that's a
whole another angle of thinking about uh
what's possible with RLM.
And then lastly, and we'll talk more
about OpenProse um but uh OpenProse as a
language uh actually enables you to
convert any coding agent into an RLM.
I'll talk a little bit more about how to
do that towards the end of the talk. Uh
and then the OpenProse repo also
contains a harness that executes it's a
coding agent harness that uh will let
you use Codex SDK or Cloud Code
underneath and do an RLM style execution
of these prose programs. So,
is Cloud Code an RLM? This is like the
the question that keeps getting asked.
And the original answer on the day
release day of the blog post was no, no,
no, it's not. Uh but it was literally
the first question that was asked or
like asked on the very same day uh to
the launch tweet. Um it's basically
saying, "Hey, this is Cloud Code
subagents, right?" Uh
go back to my rubric if you want to like
dig into some of the
the nitty-ditty nitty-gritty details.
Um but arguably now it is. So, uh over
here on the right we see Omar saying,
"Hey, congratulations Anthropic, uh
Cloud Code is finally an RLM now that
you have dynamic workflows." So, so what
changed? And I think this is an
interesting way of explaining um what's
powerful about recursive coding agents
and what RLM's even are um by using this
example. So, dynamic workflows were
released just a few weeks ago
um and they make Cloud Code recursive or
capable of doing these recursive uh
workflows.
Uh I would highly encourage you to read
this blog post called A Harness for
Every Task. It shows six different
workflow patterns that are very
powerful. Obviously, there's many more
that you can achieve.
And just to to show it, I I wrote two
uh workflows for Cloud Code. Uh one that
is explicitly not an RLM, so that's like
a hard-coded map reduce workflow, and
one that I'm arguing is, that is uh you
could kind of think of it as like deep
research over a file system. So, you
know, pick pick a handle,
um assign that to an agent, have it go
do some analysis, bring back what it
finds, etc.
Uh again, these are in the companion
repo.
Uh and then now to open prose. So, so
dynamic workflows are cool.
They're only in Claude code. They're
also not the only way to do this. So,
what if you don't like Claude code? Or
what if you do like Claude code, but you
don't want to use dynamic workflows? You
want something else. So, this is what
open prose is all about. So, open prose
is technically a programming language,
but it is not compiled by your computer.
It's compiled by your coding agent. Um,
it's a markdown spec. It's logical
English. You don't need to learn any
kind of crazy syntax.
And there's actually a command prose
write that will get Claude code or Codex
or your favorite or Pi or your favorite
coding agent to
write a dot prose dot md file for you.
Um, so in that way it's similar to the
the um,
Claude code um, ultra code command where
it like decide and write the workflows
for you.
And the
the prose has the ability to turn any
agent that's got a file system and sub
agents
into an RLM.
So, this is open source repo. You can
check it out. Um, and I've also written
uh, a little bit more in depth about
this for Turing Post in this article.
And the key thing that I want to bring
up with regards to the RLMs is that open
prose can explicitly declare the sub
agent work. So, again, I've made two
kind of demo prose dot md files that are
in this companion repo if you want to
dig into the code. I'm not going to do
that here in the slides.
Uh, where you can break a problem up
into smaller pieces that are assigned to
sub agents, verify the work of those sub
agents um, in the in the parent agent
session.
Uh, and what's even cooler is you can
actually in open prose to the features
that I added to the language or that you
can add skills
and tools as explicit dependencies. So,
you can imagine a workflow where certain
sub agent needs a very specific skill to
do its role in the workflow or must have
access to a certain CLI tool, for
example, or it can't run and do its job.
And so, there's a way in Pros to
actually wire those in as dependencies
to ensure that um not only that the way
the work is done
um
is what you want, but actually that the
sub agents are specifically configured
with the tools and skills that they need
to successfully do the work that you are
declaring in the Pros contract.
Okay, super cool. What can you actually
do? So, I've got two examples from Cloud
Dynamic Workflows, two examples from
Open Pros.
Uh repo scale migrations, this was kind
of the launch post example, refactor
like a huge thing
uh all with a big swarm in parallel and
then merge the whole thing together.
That's super cool.
Um
this idea of like go after a directory
and then deep research or deep analyze
uh or deep process in some way
recursively uh inside that is is another
example uh I have here.
You can do audits, uh bug sweeps, you
can do adversarial things such as having
a skeptical agent or um you know, a red
team
uh
set of agents uh that are going to
uh try to
uh improve the system
adversarially or in parallel.
And then uh one really cool thing that
you can do with Open Pros that I just
added recently is
kind of goes back to my very first
slide, right? So, like one day I get
this amazing result, the next day
they trade away all my
all my uh crypto currency, which is very
small, thankfully. Um,
but
like, how do we get these things to be
more reliable? And how do we get them,
you know, we we have like a golden
session and we have a great day.
And now we want to capture that and use
it over and over again. So, I built a
system where you can take a golden
session for Cloud Code, Codex Pi,
whatever you want. And it's a Prose
program that will actually have the
agent deconstruct that session and turn
it into a reusable Prose workflow, um,
that again can involve this idea of
recursive coding agents, um, to get you
to a reliable, uh, way of getting to
that golden state of performance over
and over and over again.
Recursion
Recursive coding agents for the win.
I really think this is very powerful.
RLMs just kind of blew my mind when they
first came out. And again, as you can
probably see through this talk, I've
been absolutely obsessed with applying
the ideas of RLMs to coding agents. The
three things that I hope you'll take
away from this is one, like, trust is
reliability. Like, how can we
how can we trust something that isn't
reliable? And again, my argument and
this idea of the mismanaged genius is
um, that the next step is not, um, more
raw intelligence. It's actually, uh,
behavioral. It's actually orchestration.
I personally believe that, um, RLMs
represent this new paradigm of test time
compute, inference time compute, uh,
where tool calling and reasoning are
unified. And we reason through tool
calling and we can,
uh, recursively iterate. And one of
those tools is to call another agent to
go do it on some other specific
task or subset of the problem. Uh, and
then also, I hope we settle a little bit
of this drama around like wait, like are
are LLMs
actually new? Aren't they just coding
agents? Yes, coding agents can be LLMs.
They aren't automatically LLMs.
And so I've showed a couple of different
Claude code dynamic workflows that can
turn Claude code into an LLM
as well as some ways of doing this with
open pros that you can use with any
coding agent.
So, I see this as an incredibly powerful
way of working with coding agents. I
hope you will dig in more to
recursivecodingagents.com.
But, with great power comes great
responsibility. So, until next time,
please
recurse responsibly.
Thank you very much.